[Applaudissements]
nouvelle ovation pour la bande à fifi
lors de l'avant-première de super héros
malgré lui à saint quentin en yvelines
le film ne sera la fiche que le 9
février mais après plusieurs mois de
projection exceptionnelle à travers la
france le cinquième long métrage de
philippe lachaux semble avoir déjà
rencontré son public ça fait plaisir de
voir autant de monde venir voir le film
rires nous dire des choses si gentille
après bon le film est toujours pas sorti
mais en tout cas pour l'instant ça se
passe super bien effectivement quand tu
vas aux avant premières tu as toujours
ce stress de dire est ce que le film va
plaire plus que les autres moins que les
autres
voilà est bon pour l'instant tout se
passe très bien
batman c'est moi
le premier super héros
français super héros malgré lui ou
l'histoire d'un apprenti comédien devenu
amnésique qui va s'identifier à son
personnage de fiction devenu badman il
se battra contre le mal à sa manière
épaulé comme toujours par elodie fontan
julien à rüti ou encore tarek boudali
seul absent de cette avant-première
organisée à l'ugc donc c'est là qu'on
s'amuse beaucoup on a des personnages
très différents à chaque fois un mois là
j'ai la chance de faire une militaire
qui est très loin de moi avec des
tatouages avec plein collier enfin voilà
un personnage qui ne me ressemblent peu
du coup donc on s'est éclaté julien
pareil ton personnage capillairement te
ressemble pas beaucoup oui j'ai des
cheveux donc c'est une nouveauté pour
moi pour ce rendez vous en terre
yvelinoise la troupe n'ont en revanche
pas été dépaysé et on vient du ce sont
18 on a passé nous parmi nos meilleures
années dans le 78 avec phi phi et du
coup forcément quand on revient ici
qu'on présente le film dans les yvelines
on est hyper content ça nous touche et
puis ça nous fait quelque chose donc
c'est important pour nous et actions et
bonne humeur savamment dosé deux
ingrédients qui pourraient permettre à
ce film de faire revenir au cinéma en
février des spectateurs encore un peu
frileux à l'idée de fréquenter les
salles obscures en ce moment je crois
que mon frère se prend pour le
personnage de son film de super héros
et les parties terminé sa mission